uh there's also a uh a fan theory that
uh your spider-man uh uh predecessors
toby maguire and andrew garfield might
be making a cameo in this movie you
can't uh confirm or deny
it would be amazing if they were because
they haven't told me that yet and
i actually kind of believed him for this
one look at our little guy all growing
up
did a great job
at the moment a little awkward but
i bought it
he's trying too hard he's trying too
hard to keep a secret don't they
he's trying
to get to the point where it's really
frustrating
like
like they might be doing something
but
then ain't none like i
this whole werewolf stuff old mafia yeah
yeah yeah yeah uh-huh you know that game
i think it's kind of similar where it's
like you're convinced but he's so
charming in the mafia he's like we just
love him even more like i feel like i'm
in a game of [ __ ] werewolf or mafia
where i'm like i'm not the werewolf yes
you were i promise you i am not the
werewolf
you were the werewolf baby look at him
whatever you have there you are nice
of this taping hard in or have any
knowledge of being in the next
spider-man movie
technically i feel
like like i feel i feel like i like
haven't i just said that
i want to
have you seen the
photo what what are you talking about
yeah you wouldn't see the photos for him
he's trying something no yeah it's not
possible to see a photo
that's correct
like i'm the worst detective
[Music]
ah
i heard about it
and i did see it
and it's a photoshop
noah was it
that [ __ ] was real we say no
i'm trying to manage expectations you
said that's right
he's trying to do it he's doing a good
job laughing through it yeah
you know
he is truly
giggled for eight minutes
[Laughter]
welcome back to new rockstar spider-man
no way home is one of the biggest movies
of all time raking in over 1.37 billion
dollars and at this point if you didn't
know toby mcguire and andrew garfield
cameo in this movie you are lying you
know it's out there someone else has
talked about this over the past three
weeks because all of us knew from andrew
garfield's adorably bad poker face over
the past year what a year it has been
and it's fun to go back and look at
their desperate but
bullhearted attempts to try to keep this
a secret i love them for how hard they
tried
but now with the no way home filmmakers
revealing that they actually conceived
post credit scenes for toby and andrew's
versions of peter parker we are asking
what happens to these spider-man number
two and number three and what it will
take for them to swing back up to number
one at least in their own eyes and give
these guys some self-confidence for once
this is inside marvel new rockstars
weekly marvel reaction show in nearly
four weeks actually at this point after
no way home's release the spoiler veil
has lifted and we are kicking off the
new year asking what is next both for
these characters and for the marvel
titles we are looking ahead at in 2022
i'm eric boss mt is out this week our
nerd baby new year baby recharging as he
orbits some sun and distant solar system
with the other synthetic eternals that
uh we will rotate in and out of here new
rock stars uh but he's off for this week
and joining me is long time brenden to
this show we love her jessica clements
thank you for joining us how you doing
jess i'm doing great and i also uh love
replacing mt
and i love spiderman so truly this is
great i love locking him away
in a barney crouch mad-eye moody uh
bunker don't worry i will drink my
apologies don't worry i feed him um he's
perfect he's great but it's my
time but i'm excited i'm excited
we're so happy to have you here and uh
in this episode we're gonna discuss
these uh toby and andrew post credit
scenes to no way home everything we know
about those and then we're gonna give
you a preview of the full year ahead in
marvel like are
are we really gonna wait
five months for more marvel stuff is
that how this is gonna work i don't know
maybe not we will find out but before we
dive into that we still have some
amazing designs inspired by the huge
year in marvel we just had all available
at newrockstarsmerch.com these include
our awesome strange entanglement design
her hawkeye inspired kingpin shirt and a
trust a bro moving company shirt jessica
let's talk about toby and andrew what's
her question uh first question of the
new year okay what happens to the toby
and andrew peter parker's after no way
home yes yes so quick reminder in
spider-man no way home the past variants
of peter parker cross over into the mcu
as a result of tom holland peter parker
tampering with dr strange's memory spell
the runes of kafka
everyone in alternate universes who
knows that peter parker is spider-man
has now spilled into this reality or at
least p some people who know that has
spilled in this reality but also so does
jamie fox electro even though he never
learned that information before he died
but hey hey it's okay if it doesn't make
sense because i've seen this movie five
times now and still it is too damn
charming to care about the refrigerator
logic as we say here at new rockstars
there are no plot holes there are only
week six theory videos so we'll get to
that
okay
oh
it's a philosophy of life we have and it
served us well i love it um but yeah
andrew garfield peter parker told
maguire peter parker are among these
crossovers they play a crucial role in
helping tom holland peter parker process
the death of aunt may and that includes
resisting the urge to kill norman
osborne green goblin instead give the
guy a second chance that aunt may would
have given him but tom holland peter
parker isn't the only peter who gets
morally redeemed and rescued because
andrew garfield peter parker revealed
that despite his apparent friendly
neighborhood rebound at the end of the
amazing spider-man 2 2014 saving jorge
from paul giamatti rhino and slinging
manhole covers happily at us doing bits
on police loudspeakers that was all up
assad he never actually got over gwen
stacy's death
uh who would think that a uh a
valedictorian speech wouldn't actually
change your mind when it was
pre-recorded weirdly directly in the
camera like they had some drone hovering
in front of the podium anyway i i
rewatched that recently the the camera
work is interesting to say the least but
um but he never got over her death he
stopped pulling his punches he becomes
rageful and it sounds like this peter
might have killed someone and
considering that sony's plans for the
future of that continuity included a
sinister six lineup led by harry osborne
dane de haan that might explain why no
one has heard from dan dahan in six
years it's because andrew garfield
killed it
i like i'm like yes yes yes keep going
um but but here andrew garfield peter
rescues mj from her death fall and he
sobs in relief really who rescued who
there dr strange's cape did nothing he
was too busy completing ned's insane
wizard cosplay in this movie but andrew
garfield was there at the nick of time
and saved her
thank god um then toby maguire peter
gets stabbed in the kidney by green
goblin and he survives and equips that
he's been stabbed before and uh he and
andrew garfield exchange some peace
signs and then they glow back to their
home realities but when was tobey
maguire stabbed we never saw that happen
in any of uh the three sam rainey movies
there was a planned fourth movie that
would have involved john malkovich's
vulture bruce campbell is mysterio maybe
dylan baker is lizard that would have
been fun i'm gonna guess the person who
stabbed him could have been joe
manganiello as flash thompson venom in
that reality because joe manganiello
cameoed in the harry osborne funeral
scene in the third movie
i think that guy he was only a few years
away from magic mike there was a star
born in him it could have been his time
to shine and some venom goo could have
been
splashing around that reality now in
another video i explained how the
timelines these two peters return to
along with the timelines all the various
villains returned to have been altered
so norman osborne survived but he's
still a murderer when he goes home and
there'd probably be no doc or harry
osborne drama in that timeline doc ock
still probably would have drowned
because the fusion reaction was still
out of control uh electro might have
been depowered before gwen stacy had to
flip that power plant switch i mean she
might have been able to to get out of
there before harry osborne swooped in
and grabbed her because he didn't even
know before he flew to that power plant
that gwen stacy and
spider-man and spider-man b and peter
parker he kind of put that all together
in a matter of like eight seconds and
then decided he was gonna kill gwen
stacy so had he had she not been there
in that moment when when goblin swooped
in she probably would still be alive
today yes um
but now in a recent interview with
variety no way home screenwriters chris
mckenna and eric summers were asked
about future spider-man movies with
tobey maguire and andrew garfield and
chris mckenna said quote i would hope so
i would love to see more of their
journey we even talked about oh we could
do a post-credit tag with this one we
could do a tag with that one and then
some are stroked can we do a tv show
with the two of them traveling around in
the van solving mysteries and then the
variety article ends with this
interesting description it says mckenna
smiles happy to joke about a movie he's
had to be so circumspect about for so
long but then he squirms a bit realizing
they've gone too far and then quote like
no you weren't supposed to say that he
jokes we are doing adobe and andrew in a
van going from town to town
it's meant to be a joke but clearly they
might have some ideas that they don't
want to step on anyone and so at sony's
toes
they might actually have plans
especially with andrew garfield the way
fans are reacting jessica i've been
talking for too long i want to ask you
there have been quite a few pushes for
fans to at least give garfield another
shot at playing peter parker what worlds
do you think these two peters returned
to what would their post-credit scenes
hypothetical look like and what movie
story lines should we see them in next
andrew garfield
deserves nothing more than a second
chance um after especially seeing this
movie and seeing the interviews seeing
how he is he is peter parker and he is
such a good peter parker and i feel
horrible for the way i felt about them
when it first came out like i was like i
want to see him again and i would love
that span push of him staying in the
sony universe as their version of
spider-man i think it is a lot to try to
do but i think it's a good way for sony
to still handle like that property
without with letting go of the tom
holland one it's like we're all willing
we're ready to jump on that bandwagon of
andrew garfield again keep him as yours
fool around with the multiverse we know
that there's different versions of
people now you have the chance to stick
with this property put him in morbius if
you want put him in like all of the
venoms if you want hey just go off with
him but just give him his spotlight and
andrew garfield like in that version in
his own universe and we'd still watch
both separately and i can differentiate
the two i can be like yeah these are two
different spider-mans i love this and
it's still canon so i'm gonna watch the
andrew garfield ones so i would love to
see him further like with the whole
venom situation because venom's gonna
keep staying on and i think just give
them a little bit you guys the and the
post-credits scene that we saw on venom
uh let there be carnage i was like okay
so how are they gonna translate this
into
uh no way home and it wasn't really and
i was just like okay
um i feel like i was set up i was set up
with carnage so i want there i want if
if you're gonna keep doing if you're
gonna keep doing venom you gotta give
him a little bit of spider-man and if
you can't figure out an in-between
between tom holland and lamoreau and
sony fight give give andrew garfield
give him andrew garfield give andrew
garfield a platform toby mcguire's
though yeah i like
a slow exit of tobey maguire's um i love
this re like because toby mcguire
spider-man was amazing already i loved
it when i was a child and then when he
came back for this i was like he is the
like senior to all of them and he is
constant and he's just like yeah i'm the
like straight man of this straight man
in comedy just the voice of reason and i
was like i like seeing him as like the
father of the spidermans to the
spidermans and i think this is just his
slow way to exit with the green goblin
him and the green goblin had a really
good like
just like dynamic and no way home i
don't know if we need to see them again
i think this was great and i think toby
maguire also feels the same way from
what i've seen interviews in his face
so i just i think he's a little tired
and i think he's just like don't call me
back and so i think he's good here give
andrew garfield venom morbius and then
we can tie that into blade eventually
further down the line but i think giving
sony their own i'm just saying giving
sony their own platform still is a good
idea and giving that platform andrew
garfield is a great idea i'm pushing for
that i don't know how easy it will be
with like contracts and money but that's
where i want to see them and
that's what i think that's what i think
yeah i think i can speak only as like a
fan of these movies and and someone who
has like tried in the past to write
movies and it's like worked on movies
before but like i am not a studio exec
so i'm not seeing all the same contracts
they're seeing but i think you're right
jessica i think spider-man no way home
set up it perfectly for a number of
different directions but first and
foremost the fact that fans can
completely tolerate and share their
headcanon with multiple peter parkers at
the same time coexisting across
different realities we've already been
able to do that
uh in the past by having like miles
morales yeah and into the spider-verse
so you don't need one to be animated
only one can be live action right like
i think what you just described having
andrew garfield be the spider-man of the
sony side universe that is occupied by
venom by morbius and i'm going to throw
in craven the hunter there oh yes there
you go that's the post-credits scene i
would love to see andrew garfield goes
back home and immediately like he is
pounced upon by the hunter played by air
taylor johnson and he just like puts
like a blade right up to his throat and
says you shouldn't have come home
brother you know something like that uh
we freaking wild i would have loved it
and why not why not let tom holland
continue to exist in an mcu bring him in
as a friend of miles morales and a
fourth spider-man movie or whatever the
avengers crossover movie is going to be
a friend
to um uh johnny storm in the fantastic
four movie you know he could just
continue to exist as much as you want
him and in the shared mcu but they had
that line where andrew garfield doesn't
know how as much to be as part of a team
he learned in this movie but like it'd
be fun it like embraced the fact that he
was kind of a lonely isolated figure in
his world and now he's being hunted by
craving the hunter he's being hunted by
venom he's being uh hunted by morbius by
these figures you know i think it could
really work
um
for toby i think you're right i think
toby is in a different part of his life
i i don't know how much he wants to
continue putting on that suit um and i
think it was great that he came back
it's like a miracle to see both of those
guys walk through the portals of course
but i would love if you would have a
post-credits scene for him
just have him go back into some weird
web of life in destiny space occupied by
madame webb and then you set up toby
just to be an elder statesman figure
whenever all the spider-verse convenes
to figure out what next crisis they all
have to work together he's just kind of
the benjamin franklin in the corner who
just says you don't want to go that far
guys
i'm not going to go on this mission but
here's my advice to you and he's just
the old grizzled smart cool youth pastor
in the corner
and you can still have them part of this
world but really you set up a live
action a true live-action spider-verse
that looks like the pages of the
spider-verse comics you have the webs
floating everywhere i think the fact
that they set up peter parker to have
his spider sense work when his astral
form is outside of his body suggests
that and the fact that it is just
happening now that there is a magical
connection uh to the spider sense uh as
we saw in the comics when uh miles
morales was going through the spider
verse we learned that the spider sense
was a link to all the other spider-men
across the spider verse and they called
it uh arachna frequency uh if they i
don't know if they'll ever use that word
in live action but i think there is a
good opportunity here to suggest that
the reason peter parker has this magical
sense it's nothing biological it is just
a form of magic that links all the
spider-man so i would love if toby could
just be part of that world that's great
if if sony were to play with these toys
again that i would love something they
have the line that really stuck with me
and i love it i love it it was a little
bit of a bitty joke i get it but i liked
was when they were talking about like
yeah i fought aliens yeah i fought in
space and then andrew garfield was like
i haven't done any of those things so
like
i thought a man in a rhinoceros machine
he was like i'm the lame spiderman he
was like i'm the lame version of us and
i was like you guys are pun you are
punching andrew garfield he is the
punching bag right now because you guys
recognize the right but he was punching
himself he was a self-punching bag and
toby was like no can we rewind a bit
about self-hate you guys know him
you guys owe him and i think he's and
he's doing so good those interviews he's
perfect he is peter parker he is peter
parker he's so he's fantastic
can we take a moment just to praise how
wholesome all the filmmakers and actors
have been for these past 20 years like
sam raimi has never had a negative word
to say about mark webb or andrew
garfield when he was interviewed about
this back in like 20 uh 13 2014 2015
nothing but kind words for them uh tom
holland has nothing had nothing but good
things to say andrew garfield has said
nothing but good things about toby
mcguire and tom holland like all these
guys have been set up to be so wholesome
with each other so to see them
compliment each other and love each
other and hug each other it just feels
so authentic and real it doesn't feel
like anyone was dragged back into this
franchise just to cash in like it's a
it's a team hug that they all wanted to
be part of no talk well we will see what
the future holds right so every time a
big spider-man movie comes out amy
pascal and kevin feige do their little
dance we've heard uh conflicting reports
it seems like amy pascal wants to do
another college era trilogy with tom
holland in the mcu uh but you know
there's gonna be some people at sony who
are like hey i don't know did doctor
strange need to be in this movie we
could have justified the multiverse in
some other way
i don't know i would hope that tom
holland peter parker couldn't stay in
the mcu for as long as possible but yeah
tom holland has said he doesn't want to
get in the way of other spider-man in
the future by just clinging to this role
i think he can still do this role but
just like
bring in miles morales have these two be
friends or like a big brother little
brother scenario i think it's perfect
yeah 100
easily well there's a lot of marvel
content beyond spider-man we're gonna
still be talking about spider-man on
this channel but in this episode we're
gonna talk about the coming calendar
year ahead but first using the internet
without expressvpn is like leaving your
laptop exposed at the coffee table while
you run to the bathroom most of the time
you're probably fine but what if one day
you come out of the bathroom and your
laptop is gonzo well when you connect to
an uncrypted network at cafes or
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
which can make hackers up to one
thousand dollars per person when they
sell it off but expressvpn creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so hackers
cannot steal your sensitive data it
would take a hacker with a supercomputer
over a billion years to get past
expressvpn's encryption works on all
devices phones laptops tablets and more
so you can stay secure on the go the
best part of expressvpn for me and the
new rockstar staff is how easy it is to
use we just fire up the app and click
one button to get protected the
simplicity of use and the importance of
securing your data make it a no-brainer
for us secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
marvel that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
marvel and you can get an extra three
months free
expressvpn.com we also want to thank
bespoke post for sponsoring this episode
this winter upgrade your routine with
bespoke post in their new seasonal
lineup of must-have box of awesome
collections bespoke post partners with
small businesses and emerging brands to
bring you unique goods every month i've
gotten some really cool sweaters from
them and this really cool camp chair
that folds up so small it could fit in a
glove box from winter cocktails to cozy
threads and camping gear essentials box
of awesome has collections for every
part of your life their new scorch box
looks fun with a bunch of hot sauces
from all over the country and the slash
and forge boxes come with some really
cool knives so to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com to help them
pick the right box for you they release
new boxes every month it's free to sign
up and you can skip a month or cancel
anytime each box costs only 45 bucks but
has over 70 dollars worth of gear inside
plus 90 of the everything that comes in
your box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome dot com and enter the
code marvel at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code marvel for 20 off
your first box and we want to thank
stance socks for sponsoring this episode
we've recently got a shipment of some
stance socks and we love them they are
well made super soft and have unique
designs there's nothing like running
around the house in pajamas and batman
socks on christmas morning founded in
2009 stance apparel represents a radical
reinvention of socks underwear and
active apparel with a sharp focus on
comfort quality and creativity stance
brings an atypical aesthetic alongside
some of pop culture's hottest
collaborators for the ultimate in style
and self-expression because everything
you wear should be a direct extension of
who you are and how you feel one of the
coolest parts of stance socks is the pop
culture collaborations they do they have
socks with designs from dc the office
marvel and pixar right now grab a star
wars pair with a mud horn and grogu so
you can watch the book of boba fett in
style it's cool to express yourself with
super comfortable super fun socks stance
believes that the perfect fit matters
more than fitting in that those who feel
good do good go see for yourself
register for an account at stats.com and
get 15 off your first purchase use promo
code marvel at checkout to apply enjoy
the color and comfort of a life less
ordinary with stance what's next for the
mcu after no way home
good question jessica so
um the next marvel title uh that we know
for sure in the mcu at least is doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness may
6 2022 we saw the trailer for it and the
post credits of uh spider-man no way
home that trailer is now on youtube
we're gonna talk about that a lot on the
channel so does that mean we have to
wait till may to get more mcu content
after getting it nearly weekly in 2021
well not so fast okay so first we have
morbius on the sony side of things that
comes out january 28th just mere weeks
away and our good buddy adrian toombs
michael keaton is in that movie based
off of how things left things and no way
home how connected to how do you think
morbius is going to connect jessica to
the mcu i think um
being involved i think which i pitched i
think a long time ago um i mean yes we
get michael keaton in it but i think um
it's going to be attached a lot to blade
and i know that's like a long it's gonna
be a long long long
part to happen because blade's not
coming out for a minute but i think
that's the closest he's gonna get into
the mcu because we need to remember that
uh morbius is still a sony property so
to put him in the mcu will take a lot
and a little um it can't be too big but
because it's like if you're gonna do too
big you might as well
do the spider-man thing like it has to
be pretty big so i think it has to be
small and i think a small way to let him
through the doors through uh blade so
that's how i think we're going to
connect them
but i don't think it's going to be like
a super grand gesture not to be rude to
morbius but
i don't think it is i i think we will
see some uh some mcu
uh uh morsels
only
only through spider-man no way home
though i think morbius might give us a
bit more context or make us slightly
more confused about the way no way home
left the world like it's going to be set
in some reality that has like
it has the exact version of oz corp that
was in the andrew garcon
universe right that's the same logo same
building but it also has horizon labs
that you know in the comics later gets
involved becomes like a version of
outcome x corporation uh it also has art
of the tobey maguire era of uh of peter
parker but the art is from the
playstation loading screen uh on the
game
but then you also have this weird daily
bugle that is kind of none of the others
it has like a weird
um like new york times style masthead it
doesn't have the new york post splashy
tabloid design so i think this is in
some reality that was altered so when
the interdimensional rifts open up i
think that slopped up one of these
realities and that's where morbius
exists now okay oh
okay
okay i like that i can believe that no i
can't make any promises that morbius
will uh answer any more questions than
it raises
but i think i'm excited to see this
movie just to see what exactly it is i
have a lot of questions in the movie i
watched the trailer uh last night and i
was re went to go see nightmare alley
and i watched the trailer on the big
screen again and i was like and i've
seen this trailer so many times because
it plays before like any movie right now
and i was just like
i need to see the movie i was like i
need to see the movie i have a lot of
questions i have so many questions and
it better be answered in this movie
you hear that jared leto
you hear me leno
as of this taping we don't have a
release date for moon night on disney
plus with oscar isaac playing mark
spector we saw a brief uh couple we saw
some shots of it last last year but
i'm wondering we might see this series
either in february or march or april of
this year and the reason why i'm
scheduling that in my head is because uh
disney plus right now
does not really seem ready even though
they should be they're gonna have to be
to release big nerd franchise uh weekly
shows on the same week they were gonna
do that with the hawkeye finale in the
book of boba fett premiere but then they
they s they push stuff around a little
bit so that wasn't the case so book of
boba fett seven episodes ends on
february 9th
and i am wondering if obi-wan kenobi is
going to premiere wednesday may the 4th
as of may the 4th obviously
star wars
so if that's the case moon night with
its six episodes could air from late
february to the end of april and not
overlap with any of their star wars
stuff
so we'll see i'm hoping we see moon
knight in the first half of this year um
because that would that would lead right
into the big marvel title that we're all
waiting for doctor strange the
multiverse of madness on may 6th
so
based off of those three titles it seems
like the first half of the year if moon
night does come it's gonna be kind of a
spooky scary first half of the year for
the marvel universe right like we're
getting some marvel horror titles um as
uh wanda visions seem to be going in
that direction we know we got agave
house of harkness further on down the
pipeline what did you make of the
multiverse of madness trailer when you
first saw it i loved it uh ate that [ __ ]
up uh i'm sorry as soon as as soon as we
saw wanda where she was hiding i was
like okay so she's in hiding confirmed
she is like she's not like in hiding
she's like someone's gonna come and get
me eventually and they just
every answer we had for one division
where we were like she's in so much
trouble and strange was like nah it
doesn't matter i was like oh okay so it
doesn't matter none of what she did
matters to people nothing she did well
here's my thing and i think it did
matter but other crazier things matter
so much more yeah that he can't focus on
on just the residents of uh west view
new jersey but i think it matters a lot
for her there yeah i think and that's
what i think is gonna be okay i have so
many ideas and theories about the
multiverse madness with wanda but i
think that's gonna hit her in the middle
of multiverse and madness and make her
mess up on a spell or something worse um
because she's gonna be like i have
brought pain to people like i can't do
this like this is the our magic isn't
just magic it ruins lives and so i think
she's gonna recognize that in the movie
because we know her she's great um but
there's so much to take in from the
multiverse of madness trailer there's so
much there's a lot
i'm gonna do more videos because that's
even newer stuff that i found in there
though oh god blew my mind i want to ask
you craziest cameo do you think we will
see in multiverse of madness
i haven't thought about that because
after i saw the doctor strange fighting
himself i was like this is the craziest
part i was like
this is nuts enough for me
i'm thinking let me give a second the
craziest cameo in that well that's the
thing he can make anyone who do you
think it is who do you think it is i
mean i think i think uh patrick stewart
in front of a chess set oh you're gonna
you think this is this is it i think
this is it i think this is their best
opportunity to bring in mutants okay uh
i think they'd be crazy not to they
gotta do it they gotta start bringing in
mutants the window is closing i think
it's gonna be moniker
um and it's not gonna be that monica
rambo yeah i don't think it's like a
crazy cameo because we've already seen
her but i think she's gonna come back
before we see her again in secret
invasion and i think this will be it i i
think we'll see some tva elements it
looks like there's a time door in that
trailer i think we're gonna see loki
gator crawl in there classic loki maybe
show up eliath
might see a little king might see a
little king oh young kang young
yeah okay so i guess now thinking
outside the box there's a lot of cameos
that could come up because this is just
now like portals upon portals upon
portal it's like we're closing [ __ ] down
um but yeah i if that's the introduction
to the x-men i'm fine with that i'm
completely content with that it seems
like it's coming so soon it seems like
it's coming so soon
just five months away ooh now the one
disney plus marvel title that we know
for sure is coming uh in in summer 2022
is gonna be miss marvel uh kamala khan
that was uh they didn't give a time of
year for any of the other ones but it
sounds like that one will be summer now
does that mean june summer doesn't mean
august summer we don't know but that is
coming at some point in the summer along
with july 8th 2022 thor love and thunder
um so we have seen no trailer for it yet
we are now in trailer season it's going
to be an exciting first half of the year
just for these trailers as they come out
because you know that's going to be a
wild i i heard somewhere that uh taika
waititi shot most of that movie in
australia just so he could not have to
like get everything approved through
marvel because they're in a completely
different time zone they're thousands of
miles away and if he does that he
doesn't have to keep asking for
permission for everybody that's so funny
oh my god of course he would of course
um now she-hulk with tatiana maslany
playing jennifer walters is confirmed
for the year 2022 we don't know yet but
i think that would also be a good one to
come out in summer so whenever in the
summertime miss marvel comes out she'll
could come out on the other end of the
summer um
sooner the better i think because there
are so many titles in the pipeline are
we gonna not get to some of these until
2025 like what is going on you know the
series exists you have most of them
wrapped so what's taking so long just
release some of them at the same time
like you have so much content you know
you don't need to do that one at a time
especially if you're like
star wars and marvel at the same time i
think or animated in live action
we'll watch both
we'll we'll watch both we will watch all
of it we'll do we'll do after shows for
all of it you know we don't care i think
the biggest date potentially of the year
is going to be september 9th to 11th
2022 because that's going to be disney's
d23 conference yeah and along with
comic-con that's when disney rolls out
their big reveals in terms of their
because they have to like reassure their
investors their shareholders
everything that they have planned in the
future so in addition to learning a
bunch of stuff about
marvel we're going to learn a lot about
star wars and everything else pixar um
but expect that date to be we're gonna
probably see our first looks at blade at
the marvel's guardians volume three
ant-man squanto mania and hopefully
we'll get some news about the fantastic
four whatever the next avengers team-up
movie is whatever their x-men plan is i
think that's all going to be then early
september now another non-mcu title on
uh the pipeline here is going to be
spider-man across the spider-verse
october 7th 2022 of all these that might
be the one i am most excited for oh
yeah it's going to be great
yeah i just uh re-watched
kelly and i watched all the spider-man
movies um because i i had seen no way
home a few times she hadn't seen no way
home yet and i had been meaning to do a
uh like a full because i i'd rewatch
select titles select scenes from certain
movies but i hadn't just sat down and
marathoned them so kelly and i did that
and man
into the spider verse 2018 it to me it's
still tops it's
really good and it's so good the writing
is so good and i can't wait to watch
this movie and start off immediately
with like a good like he knows now he's
not learning to be spider-man he's
already spider-man so like what is
happening in this one i'm very excited
my hope is that it doesn't do what the
lego movie did because the first lego
movie was so good groundbreaking
animated movie that was not uh that was
not pixar disney animation it blew all
of our minds it had this kind of cool
meta quality to it and then we were all
excited and the second lego movie came
out did some crazy mind bendy stuff with
time travel really came and went no one
saw that movie you cared about that
movie i didn't i hope this isn't the
case with across the spider verse i
assume it won't happen with across the
spider
maybe they'll learn their lesson because
of the lego movie i love the lego movie
that movie was great the movie i think
about all the time i like the second one
it's just the thing with animated movies
because these high quality ones take so
many years to do
like the kids who love them when the
first one came out are all kind of like
a lot of them have aged up into moody
teenagers or parents who uh who have
newborns who aren't gonna rush to the
theater to see them you know so you see
that a lot with like the pixar films
sometimes the animated sequels uh just
don't have the thunder like finding dory
monsters university cars 2 they don't
always have the thunder toy story broke
the mold i think lightyear is going to
blow our
minds
this summer when that comes out so good
oh um i'm super excited for that movie
now interesting uh reveal that a lot of
people didn't really hear when this came
out but we are going to get a werewolf
by night halloween special so we can
assume that's going to be october 2022.
that's going to be an interesting one i
i assume that's gonna tie in with some
of these other horror titles um but uh
don't sleep on werewolf by night we're
gonna be doing some videos on that of
course this year to explain who uh who
werewolf is and who the werewolf is in
the marvel comics jack russell is his
name yes it is the name of a dog but
it's also his name it's a goofy one but
it's fun
now interesting title coming up right
after that black panther wakanda forever
november 11th 2022 we hope there's been
all these rumors that there's been uh
some production troubles with this movie
one can understand they obviously had to
do a lot of uh reconfiguring how that
story would even work um but yeah i i
think was a fandango someone did a
survey of fans black panther wakanda
forever topped the list of the title
that fans were most excited for coming
up in uh 2022. what are you looking
forward to with this one jessica i'm
excited for every part of it what i'm
nervous about is how much they'll be
taking out the further they keep pushing
it because now i'm like you guys i feel
like you're setting you know how like
the post credit scenes are set up for
other movies and going forward and it's
like okay first off you guys were behind
this movie and now you're ahead of this
movie so that means you're already gonna
have to cut some stuff out and then
you probably have to add new lines you
gotta and that's what i'm getting
nervous about because that's where you
kind of miss me with wonder woman 84
where i was like there's too many hands
in the pot there's too many hands in the
pot and i'm nervous that we're gonna get
it was so good from where it was and
then like
we would move with the timeline and how
we're shifting it too much there's gonna
be too many people correcting stuff and
then it won't make sense
so my entire fear from this is from like
a writer's standpoint of like how are
you guys going to be doing it um but i
am completely excited for black panther
because i just want to see where it's
going to go and we have no idea of where
it's going to really go um so
so i'm just excited to see what happens
i know that like the cast casting's
always great with that so i i have no
um no doubt that it's going to be great
but it's just like i'm like
oh hurry up
just hurry up and give me something yeah
yeah i what my my concern with this is
that
uh kind of the way black widow was
delayed so many times it felt like it
was a movie from a different era like
why are we just getting this story now
yeah i don't want that with black
panther it was so great one of the many
things that was great about the first
black panther film was how forward
looking it did it really felt like this
is the the moment it came out it felt
like the most important marvel movie yes
in so many ways it had some of the best
production design we had ever seen so i
want the next one to also feel that way
that it feels like it is the beginning
of a new chapter so
this might be controversial but i'm okay
with them just delaying this movie until
martial
so we're ready what their game plan is
completely ready yeah like
i think fans will still show up for it
uh i think you know use the multiverse
to kind of redefine uh your lineup of
the mcu and then just like start fresh
because if it feels like it's too much
steeped in the past and if it comes out
like late 2022 or realistically summer
2023 or something like that if they have
to delay it again like
i i don't want the story to feel to be
holed into past versions of every chair
i wanted to be forward-looking that just
means that like for 2022 we probably
wouldn't see
well i mean i guess we got some of the
fighters and um falcon and the winter
soldier so i guess we could get that
again yeah but we wouldn't see any of
the main cast in any of the other
properties until like 2023. i mean what
i'd love to see is like i know we have
so many announced disney plus series but
like couldn't you do a uh a bucky io
movie uh disney plus series rather like
um like bucky as a as a warrior with the
dora melange i would love to see that
mini series uh in wakanda like there's
lots of like that's the thing when you
have a great setting you want to place a
tv series there when you have a great
character arc you kind of want that to
be a movie in general so you know like
if you just have a character learning a
lesson over a course of a week that's
the story that works better usually as a
movie um but like when you have such a
rich setting like i want to have like
like five different series set just in
wakanda because it's like the coolest
location we've ever seen in the mcu it's
a shame that we've spent so much time
there you know it costs so much money
you know it costs so much money that
decides i know
use the mandalorian lightbox green
screen thing he can make it
cheap
you can make it you don't have to spend
that much at the very least can we
please turn disneyland parks like
nothing against avengers campus but i
would rather walk the streets of wakanda
then that'll be kind of safe around
avengers campus walk through garages to
walk through
um okay um so also confirmed
surprisingly for 2022 i am groot james
gunn confirmed this i didn't think it
would be coming this soon but it will be
coming by the end of the year and that
might be because it will probably lead
into the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special that's coming to disney plus
december 2022 now james gunn has said he
uh wants to make this feel similar to uh
the star wars holiday special that came
out right after the first film in uh and
it came out i think 1978 which is super
campy and weird but it was the first
thing that introduced boba fett to the
world through an animated uh uh sequence
that happened in that and uh i'd be
curious to see how this could actually
feel like an mcu canon celebration you
know that'll be fun now just kind of
wrapping up other titles we know about
we were thinking we would see secret
invasion at some point 2022 we don't
know if for sure that will be 2022. i
just don't know where in the calendar it
would release as well as it sounds like
we're gonna get a new season of what if
we just don't know they wanted to do it
annually um i don't know if that will
come out in 2022 uh but i hope so and
then as we look ahead to 2023 we're
going to get a new season of loki uh the
marvels captain marvel 2 is going to
come out february 17th 2023 guardians of
the galaxy volume 3 finally
coming may 5th 2023 ant-man the wasp
quantomania july 28 2023 and then in
november 3rd 2023 marvel has this date
sectioned off it's an unannounced marvel
film we don't know what it will be so
the options for that are we could see
blade herschel are coming back from that
eternals post credit scene we may
finally see our fantastic four film
there um this could be uh a new avengers
title um there's a couple different
options here i would imagine uh a
november release blade probably i think
it's gonna be a blaze option for that
and then we also have echo we have the
house of harkness and then we have some
animated shows we have marvel zombies we
have spider-man freshman year and we
have x-men 97 yeah so i feel like
disney's gonna feel okay dropping
animated series at the same time
action i feel like they have to they're
going to there's so much they're gonna
make so they're going to need to to kind
of co-release some of these things x-men
97 baby
97.
how are you gonna how are you gonna do
x-men 97 and where we don't even have
the mutants in the mcu yet how are you
gonna i know that's why i'm saying
multiverse of madness has to be where
mutants start to get introduced right
you can't breathe how dare they bring
them back and then be like but they're
not in the movies yet they're not here
yet oh
i'm excited well that is it for this
episode of inside marvel we have a lot
to talk about this year it's gonna be a
great year uh jess i can't wait to have
you back mt's gonna be back here on
inside marvel of course we got tommy
right now doing wookie leaks with me
it's gonna be a huge year for star wars
2021 not a huge year for star wars
content other than bad batch but now it
seems like we're gonna have like a
disney plus uh marvel level releases for
star wars content so wikileaks can be a
weekly thing what did you call it it's
wookie leeks wookie leaks yeah that's
our star wars episode jess where have
you been i've been retweeting something
i'm gonna binge watch them all when the
show is over that's what i did with oh
no you gotta watch it week by week this
show is great with you guys fitness show
i watched it all at the end
anyway don't forget to check out our
many great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow jessica at lulu underscore
clements or just lulu clemens depending
on what app you're on and then subscribe
to inside marvel wherever you get your
podcasts thank you for watching thanks
for joining me this week jess happy new
year
we'll see everybody next time
bye everybody
you